Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
What's going on guys.
This is Rob and we are, uh, we're going to perform an experiment here.
We're going to perform a test on,
we are going to cover the first part of the origin of the teenage mutant Ninja
turtles, or at least the new origin from IDW 2012 run,
which as far as I'm aware is the current run, right?
It's still ongoing at this point.
I think there's like 110 issues or something like that,
but we're going to conduct an experiment here.
And the reason why is because this is the nature of being a YouTuber.
I get this question all the time. Like I want to start a YouTube channel.
What do I do?
One of the core aspects of being a YouTuber is to understand your analytics,
right into look at your, your, what your fan base wants.
You can look at your comments,
but the issue you have with comments is only a very,
very small percentage of your fan base will ever actually comment on a video,
right? Like that video that we did on the last run.
And it has like 110,000 views, right. But like 1800 people commented.
And so at the end of the day, if of those 1800 people,
a thousand want to see more Ninja turtle stuff, well,
we can't make a YouTube video based on that. Right. I mean, we could,
but it wouldn't really be beneficial for like continuing to grow the channel.
And so the only way to really know what it is that people want is to one
experiment like this. And then to, to follow up by looking at analytics, right?
Does the video perform well? Are people watching a lot of it? That's the test,
right? That's, that's the nature of what it means to be a YouTube.
It's one part listening to your fans.
And then one part listening to the fans who don't actually say anything, right.
And just going by what your YouTube analytics say. So what we're doing here is,
again, as far as I'm aware of, I've done some research and I could be wrong,
but I don't think I am. As far as I'm aware,
IDW basically restarted the Ninja turtles run in 2012 with this
particular story. And the idea is that this is kind of going this,
this sort of jumps back and forth between the past and the present.
We're not going to do that. Instead.
What we're going to do is kind of focus on past events and then sort of bookend
into what's going on in the current moment,
because one leads directly to the other.
And so what we end up doing here is basically picking up about 18 months before
the present day, at the time the story was being written.
But what you have here are a couple of different people.
You've got April O'Neil and you've got a guy named Chet,
really Chet Allen looks like his,
what his name is for those people who are really familiar with them to turtles
that might ring a bell for you. For me, it doesn't right.
It doesn't really seem particularly important here.
But the thing that matters is that what they're doing is they're conducting a
bit of an experiment involving a couple of different,
or really a few different animals, right?
One comes in the form of a rat and the other comes in the form of turtles. Now,
the reason why this experiment is being conducted,
it really comes by way of a guy by the name of Dr. Stockman himself.
While he's talking directly to a guy named general crane, or at least, you know.
Talking over the phone, but it's a little direct conversation.
And the idea is that.
Well,
crane has basically provided stockmen with a kind of mutagen and using that
along with their own resources,
that what Stockman is looking to do is seemingly try to develop super soldiers
while at the same time use animals and the process.
And what they're doing here is they're kind of looking at the progress of this
experiment,
which comes in the form of what's called Terrapinn human bio armor synthesis,
and then road denture psychotropic serum as well, effectively.
It's one experiment on the turtles and then one experiment on the rat itself and
the experiment for the most part to be progressing in so far as they don't
really seem to have like a measurable determination of whether or not this rat
is able to develop, uh, develop sentience.
But at the same time they haven't died.
So the fact that they haven't died is a good thing.
And then it's just a matter of kind of controlling the experiment a bit to see
what sort of see how things especially go from here.
But the explanation for this really comes by way of a woman named Lindsey. Now,
April O'Neill for her part is really just seems like the new girl here.
She really just kind of seems to be the new person.
Who's really more enamored with the, the animals themselves,
more so than the experiments,
but doesn't really seem to fully understand the experiment.
And so when she asks the question of Lindsay, what's going on with all this,
like the Ninja turtles, these, these little turtles are adorable. The rats,
not very attractive.
Lindsay answered the question and basically saying that the Brad himself is part
of the psychotropic drug test,
where they're trying to essentially split the rats consciousness, right?
Split its mindset between its animal instinct and its ability to achieve
sentience, to have human level cognition.
And seemingly the idea here seems to be,
to build on its human level cognition to essentially turn into a walking,
talking rat, right. That more or less seems to be the case.
So this obviously it's winter, right?
This is obviously like the origin of splinter himself. And so from there,
what you end up doing is picking up kind of over period, as a timer,
you sort of jump ahead three months later, different things like that.
And you ended up finding out that what April had Donna,
she had actually named the turtles. The rat's name is already splintered, right?
This is where did the name of the rat?
And the reason why they called that is literally because of what they're trying
to do, right? Splint the way a split the way in which it's mind works,
where I created like a splinter and its ability to be, you know,
to develop cognitive abilities versus its animal instincts. Right?
So it already has this name, but for the turtles themselves,
because of the fact that that April basically majored,
or at least has a history of Renaissance, a one-on-one this semester,
or at least the semester she's in school, she ends up naming them after,
you know, Renaissance art, right. Renaissance painters.
So you've got Leonardo Donatello's Michelangelo and of course,
Raphael and Raphael's established as the guy who's a little bit feisty,
which since is a Dick. Here's the, here's the thing about Rafio right.
The guy's kind of a jerk, but at the end of the day, man, Rafi,
L's got at work counts. And that's the funny thing, right?
That's the funny thing about the Ninja turtles, right? That's that's,
that's the important thing about these Minda turtle guys, right.
If I here's the thing, if I had to team up with one Ninja turtle,
it would be Rafiel Leonardo is cool, but he's too by the book, try these two,
like, Whoa, you know what? We got to follow a splitter and you know,
what splinter wants us to do and you know, do the right thing.
And Michelangelo is like, he's cool to hang out with.
I would get beers with Michelangelo because like he's, he's, he looks fun.
And like, the problem with Donna tallow is like, he's too techie,
but he's like the MKBHD of like the Ninja turtles world. Right.
Let's let's where you'd like the marquees Brownlee of Ninja turtles.
So it's kind of like, okay, I want to hang out with Rafio
because Raphael's just, he's just, he's just the guy, right?
Like he's just the guy, here's my question for you guys.
Like if you could hang out with one Ninja turtle, which one would it be?
That's my question for you guys. But nonetheless,
the fact that higher level thinking within splinter become, you know,
kind of what's achieved Willy comes by way of the fact that while April O'Neil
is inside the buildings, sort of,
I think that splinter comes running up on her essentially with a CD.
And this has all the information of what's going on there, right?
The confidential property, the experiment that's being done on the turtles,
right? Human XO armor, synthesis, the experiment being done on splinter himself,
how it can be applied military battle and strategy right there.
So they're essentially looking to take this, uh, of this,
this research and weaponize it, this comes to,
comes to bear one when he does that. And two,
when she's met by the arrival of what are basically ninjas,
or they look like footclan members, right? And when they show up here,
of course, their goal is to one,
take the research and then two to take the animals where at least see me just
kind of take the animals. And so of course the disk is destroyed in the attack.
And then they immediately go after, uh, the, the mutagen, basically the,
the substances. And they go after the animals, but splinter himself,
realizing what's going on, goes and pulls the fire alarm. Right.
Which is a genius maneuver. Because what it'll do is it'll bring the authority,
right? It'll bring cops,
it will bring the police department and realizing these guys will realize that
themselves, that basically the whole process kind of gets hurried, right?
So they ended up snatching up the Ninja turtles. They throw,
or really snatch up the turtles themselves.
They throw them in a bag and in turn, of course, splinter still kind of,
kind of sitting around there. And when the cops show up,
then of course the guys have basically taken off by then.
Now if we're splinter forest park chases after these guys, right?
Like literally hunts these guys now. And that's kind of a cool thing, man.
They were not prepared. Like nobody's prepared for a rat, right.
This like sentience,
but it's what makes splinter so cool is despite his small size.
And despite the fact that he really is just a rodent that weighs a couple
pounds, if that he gets the upper hand on these guys, right? He goes,
wind up on one of these guys, claws the hell out of him. They dropped the bag,
right. They ended up like throwing the rat out of the way.
And the bag goes crashing down onto the ground and splinter falls alongside it.
But he's exposed to the mutagen and the chemicals and substances all basically
crack, right? Like,
like literally the turtles themselves and everything are all kind of exposed to
this, this substance of sorts. And so as a result of that,
you have a cat that ends up stumbling across this and it actually ends up taking
one of the turtles where the intention of consuming it.
And so seeing what's going on, of course, like, you know,
rats and cats are basically like mortal enemies, splitters. Like now son,
we didn't have any of that. Right? Like you're not making often,
you don't make it off of my turtle. It's a little weird to see a,
see a rat kind of guarding his turtles in such a way,
probably because they're so helpless,
but like a kind of knock-down drag-out fight goes on between these two.
And this is kind of cool. The cat of course, is of scratching the hell out of,
uh, out of splinter.
And then basically making off with the turtle splinter continues to go on and
try to fight by tries to fight on behalf of, of getting his turtle back.
But at the end of the day, one of the turtles is just kind of left box, right?
Like this, this turtle that fell, it seemingly left behind here.
And the reason why is because one,
we don't really see what happens to it when a splinter, when the,
when the cat basically ends up taking off after just one or gets them that I
just wonder dots that I write and like takes, it, takes it away from him.
And since I kept fleeing for his life,
but the other thing is that really only three turtles seem to be inside this
bag. Right.
And we know that because of the fact that when the Ninja is basically tracked
down, at least come back down to try to try to attain splinter. And the,
the bag of course filled with the turtles.
But at the end of FOLEO splinter is of dragging them into a, into a manhole,
into a sewer drain and only three turtles fall down with it. Right?
So it's splinter and these three turtles and that's it. Now of course,
this leases splinter passing out. It leads to the turtles. You know,
looking like they're kind of awake.
Analog is kind of hard to tell when it's turtles,
but you ended up having the cat who seems to have seen all of this. And so some,
some period later, we're not really given a definitive timeframe, right?
We're not really given an instance where it's like four hours later, you know,
splinter basically comes to. And when he does,
he's able to walk upright and he's able to speak English.
And so this basically means a heat that this goal has been achieved.
That's splinter himself has achieved higher level reasoning.
Now there is a lot more going on to splinter than what we're initially told
here.
And that's one of the important things to understand is that it's not something
as simple as like splinter became Cynthia.
And now he somehow knows martial arts because you know, when you gain sentience,
you learn martial arts,
especially when you're a rat and you teach it to turtles.
There's a little bit more going on with regards to splinter here.
But when he comes to, he basically ends up looking around and he's like,
one of them was like, what happened? And it's like, he's like,
what in the world is like my turtles. And they're like, yeah, man,
we're turtles. And like,
this is the first part of the origin of teenage meet Minda turtles.
So here's a cool thing.
And I'm going to throw this out here before I finish this video.
Ninja turtles is legit. Like I never, I didn't really think it was,
I was sitting here like, okay. So like the last Ronan did really well.
And the last is kind of a cool story. Like I can get behind this story.
It's really interesting. I dig this up, but I was like,
I don't know if like the tea that she has on 12 run is going to be any good,
but I was like, you know what? We'll read it. We'll buy it on Comixology.
We'll read it. And, uh, here's the thing, man, dude, it's, it's amazing.
I never realized midget turtles like Ninja turtle comics were this good man.
I've wished someone had told me before, but Ninja turtles is amazing.
Like it's really, really good. So with that being said, guys,
we're gonna bring this video to an end.
If you are new here to come and explain and make sure you guys have the sub
button to become part of the Robb core. If you guys enjoyed this video,
make sure you drop a light and that will catch you all later.
Bruce,
[inaudible].